former over watts Pro and popular
streamer to Fran recently got hit with a
30 day Twitter and I have no idea why
not because I'm [ __ ] at using Google but
because this dude said at least three
different things on stream last week
that could have pissed off twitch
whatever the hell happened it's
definitely not the first time to Fran's
been banned but let's try to figure out
what exactly went wrong here now de
France is one of North America's most
popular overwatch players and last week
he got hit with a thirty-day twitch ban
now right after the incident dufranne
tweeted out saying that stupid [ __ ] and
being ignorant on stream was what got
him banned now I half jokingly think
that he doesn't really understand why he
got banned in the first place because
like I said off the top there's at least
three different things he said on stream
that could have had twitch swinging the
banhammer there's this rant against the
teammate that he thinks is [ __ ] both
loser
[ __ ] you you piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] piece
of [ __ ] [ __ ] and a player dude loser
uninstall the [ __ ] game you [ __ ]
piece of show oh my [ __ ] god holy
[ __ ] you [ __ ] piece of and there's
this rant that we can't find footage of
where he tells a player using an off
meta support to go kill themselves then
there's this third rant where he just
loses it on someone in his own chat the
friend you're not my hero anymore I
don't give a [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm not your
[ __ ] hero I've got some sweaty
[ __ ] nerd sitting in a [ __ ]
basement playing computer you could go
[ __ ] yourself I'm not a [ __ ] hero
go find [ __ ] another hero are you
[ __ ] stupid or what in his initial
tweet de France said he was gonna fight
the ban which all right man you do you
and then choked later on that when he
returned to stream it would have a war
family-friendly by now if you know
anything about to Fran you know he has a
reputation for being toxic impact dates
back all the way to 2017 when
competitive overwatch was just getting
started and he signed with selfless
gaming but just two days after selfless
qualified for season zero
contenders the friend was suspended by
blizzard and dropped from the team
apparently he was caught throwing
matches streaming porn and just
generally being toxic and the TWiT
longer he posted at the time is pretty
on brand to say the least here's a
little excerpt from the twit lager I
honestly do not give a [ __ ] what happens
to me in my [ __ ] career you can all
go [ __ ] yourselves de Franny's never
really talked about why he got kicked
from selfless but since then his
ex-teammate iman has come to his defense
I mean I was on out of all people I
probably know how to family being a pro
scene he just needs to he needs to get
the phrase long as a friend gets his fix
of like memes like heavy memes and the
frame will be just finding a protein so
long as he's able to stream so while
being on a protein what the one thing
different has been pretty open about is
how being a professional overwatch
player has affected his mental health
and maybe even led to some of this
erratic behavior after all this to Fran
focused on streaming for a while and
then eventually he signed a contract
with the Atlanta rain just before the
start of the second overwatch season and
fans were stoked because despite his
bans and his erratic behavior de Fran
has always been one of the most popular
people in the overwatch community and I
mean he even had the best-selling jersey
of the year but oddly halfway through
the season - Fran announced he was
leaving Atlanta to stream full-time
again and that kind of brings us to now
because since he returned to streaming
full-time he's been banned a couple of
times I'm bad dude what the [ __ ] did I
do
what did I do
I didn't do anything for abusing game
disconnects soft throwing games and just
well-being de France this way - pseudo
retirement from the overwatch league de
France popularity has continued to grow
and he recently broke his own peak your
chute number topping out at over 20k
and honestly yeah des franc can be a bit
of a dick but the overwatch community
seems to love them and it's never seemed
like malicious with him bluefish nip to
the right so we can see chat please
move camera oh you can't see chat okay
okay what about this what about this
[Music]
whoa fly and that brings us to last week
where the Fran
first stuff that's typically him so
typical in fact we don't actually know
what he specifically said or did that
got him banned and the overwatch
community is not at all surprised about
this so there you have it de frança
banned fur well being - Fran and he says
he's going to be more family friendly
when he returns to stream but who
[ __ ] knows only time will tell what
the Fran has never really talked
extensively about why he got kicked from
selfless his his ex-teammate isn't it
well the Fran has never extensively
talked about what got him kicked from
selfless his x-x-x can't [ __ ] speak
English well the Fran has never really
talked extensively about what it
well the friend has never really talked
extensively about why he got kicked from
selfless his ex-teammate imam has since
come to who's his defense holy [ __ ]
Imam has never Imam Jesus